okay this is where I spend all my time
yet somehow my ex-wife owns half of it
not bitter at all good for you
we got baseball over here and got
football right there and then hunting
and fishing in the back I am in this
hockey puck has been here since Jimmy
Carter was present you think a sport
with a bunch of white boys beating each
other up would be more popular in Texas
so you want to head out
oh my grandson's Ben wants some weights
Shelly how can you just lift a soup can
or something the other grandson the
pretty one with the hair huh all right
we'll send it by we'll give him the
family and friends discount how big a
discount yeah depends on how much fun we
have night are you putting a price on my
affections you gonna regret it
[Music]
[Music]
excuse you mr. valor yeah that'd be me
I'm Georgie calling Tucker's grandson oh
yeah they're very pretty
hang on a sec I got a deal with this guy
okay thank you Tom
so here you go hey Suraj you're asking
about now that's a good choice very
solid and then I just brought this one
long to show you just in case later you
know you get serious about fishing well
I'm pretty serious yeah you know I had
that feeling what's your name
Jim Jim well Jim this rods a little
pricey it's probably cost to that one
but it's worth every penny and that's
what broad I use well then that's the
one I want well that's a good choice
now with a rod like this you want to use
live bait and we don't carry that here
too but down the street is adds bait and
tackle shop and if you tell them Dale
sent you you'll take care of it
I appreciate that so take her over there
to Bernice and she'll ring you up Thanks
Hey and it bring me back some catfish
you bet yeah you're really good salesman
well yeah not only that I get a kickback
on everybody I sent down two ads you're
awesome 35 cents off goober
peanut butter enjoy in the same jar
think about how much time he'd save Hey
they'll give you a good price on those
weights better they gave me a job damn
he did have fun last night what kind of
job salesman
well congratulations I'm gonna learn a
lot from him he's real good at getting
people to spend money on stuff they
don't need well I don't know if I like
the sound of that you know what I like
the sound of catching a kerfuffle at the
church today pastor Jeff promised
Patricia Richard she could sing how
great thou art on Sunday but I had
already printed in the bulletin that
Karen Baker was gonna sing it they
agreed to it too wet but it was touch
and go
what's a kerfuffle not bad hey hey how
was your first day at work
amazing I made $38 on commissions alone
well good for you
what's for dinner meatloaf oh I think
I'm gonna go out to eat no you're not
we're having dinner as a family yeah but
I got money now and I can do what I want
and what I want is a chimichanga cheese
I wanted to me Chandler from T cheese
they do have a good margarita you were
eating here so are you I don't care what
you do later
do walk out of that door Georgie that's
a kerfuffle Missy let this be a lesson
to you the love of money is the root of
all evil
hey you would not believe the wheeling
and dealing I did today
I'm playing the high school and the
University against each other
what do you say we go out to dinner JC's
is good ooh chimichangas I think this
show is teaching you bad lessons don't
worry I'm a slow learner
[Music]